mais pas question pour autant pour le
gouvernement de supprimer purement et
simplement les lois pasqua debré ce qui
provoque la colère des sans papiers qui
défilent est aujourd'hui à paris un an
tout juste après l'évacuation de
l'église saint bernard vallet lhermitte
nathalie gal un mouvement de foule en
tout début de manifestation fodé sylla
le président de sos racisme est
littéralement expulsé par une centaine
de manifestants
la course poursuite à travers les rues
de paris va durer plus d'un quart
d'heure fodé sylla est obligé de partie
fodé sylla n'est pas représentative de
ce mouvement il n'a pas à se montrer on
en a assez des gens qui cale à double
discours sur l'immigration
un an après l'évacuation musclée des
sans papiers de saint bernard où les
portes de l'église sur cassis à coups de
hache
toutes les associations de gauche en
deux rendez vous près de 2000 personnes
avec toujours les mêmes figures de proue
et les mêmes slogans des papiers pour
tous et surtout l'abrogation des lois
pasqua debré
en attendant du bourg leur maman
qu'ils viennent les promesses de la
campagne électorale c'est à dire
l'abrogation des lois pasqua debré c'est
qu'ils signifient leur annulation pure
et simple et non pas leur aménagement je
voulais lancer aujourd'hui sa part
atterrit aujourd'hui près de la moitié
des 300 sans-papiers de saint-bernard
seraient régularisés
leur porte-parole reconnaît ces avancées
mais entendent surtout maintenir la
pression à la veille de l'élaboration
des nouveaux projets de loi sur
l'immigration